Oh
I thought that the half-and-half studio
and they showed how they shape concrete
into everyday objects it was very
interesting because one doesn't pay so
much attention to concrete a towel I
just know it's put in buildings
now I'm pleasantly surprised that you
can't come face to face with makeup and
look at the collapse and you'd arrive in
such intimately
yes I think it's a great platform for us
to promote design I think typically
Flores may not be considered in the
design industry / see they are taken
through the process of designing with
flowers I think it's amazing when i saw
the program lineup gosh there's so many
interesting people in singapore and i
think a lot of the time we don't really
think of the echo as a place where you
can explore all these boys image design
things
when they come here we show people that
goes on behind the scenes is it gives
people a deeper insight into the entire
process and we love that and it allows
people who appreciate sign a lot better
i think is great like I I really like
the fact that sign shows has been around
for three years now I hope they are more
nobody's angry
I think Riza greatly it's going to
really meet them never little company
before and I guess you got a template
bank and it also caused retailer stories
it's always a guilty we are audited we
about the disease how many cousins had
something do something
she's really insight into the design
team and I didn't know you can actually
punch on into so many different aspects
so I thought there was something
refreshing for me
it's been a real eye-opener getting to
hear while pushing to the planning and
design of the South Beach and then
seeing the result the tour I'm so glad
I'm here perfect for design shows I
don't think I would have known pieces
like this on my own
well i hope that be inspiring for them
we hope that they will understand that
there are lots of fellows actually in
singapore and around the region
I guess the learning objective would be
a creativity in those things of the
future I hope my stuff inspires people
to create a single one
we really try to create a place where
they could reflect neighborhood within a
house and that was something that very
meaningful that's why you know we wanted
to create spaces so that you could
actually have a much richer experience
by coming up in constructing mother's
well today is an opportunity for us to
share but the red house we want to see
how the community can participate the
design trailer itself is a starting
point for the community to enjoy what is
prepared for everyone for the next
generation
I hope that they take away about how
design actually contribute to see how we
actually done your space that doesn't
only look good by actually contributed
to the entire business to an identity
it's really accessible and not
intimidated for like the lay person to
appreciate and enjoy try and make a
point to like come back every year or
events you because I really enjoy